parmi ces portraits de famille on a des
ministres de la famille il y 3 ministre
soûlé bourbon louis de breteuil qui
verriez vous qui êtes donc ministre des
finances de louis xiv son passé sa vie
semble tout droit sortie d'un livre
d'histoire henri-françois de bretagne en
décembre 1943 paris le dixième marque de
sa famille après avoir passé sa jeunesse
dans la ville lumière et décide en 1967
de s'installer dans ce château de
famille construit à choisel dans les
yvelines au xviie siècle sous le règne
d'henri iv
la structure était à l'abandon depuis
1945 qui avait failli tomber aux mains
des promoteurs pendant cette période
moi j'adorais ce château depuis que je
suis tout petit la première fois que je
suis venu ici je crois que j'avais 5 ans
et je m'en souviens encore avec le
cuisinier du château qui avait connu le
roi edward said les grandes
manifestations et caetera et j'estimais
que c'était mon droit et l'amour je vais
pour ce lieu qui devait m'amener à le
conserver pour préserver les lieux henri
françois de breteuil a démarré dès la
fin des années 60 une vaste opération de
restauration
en parallèle le marquis décide d'ouvrir
ses portes au public en 1969 avec 5000
visiteurs dès sa première année pour
leur raconter l'histoire de ses ancêtres
le propriétaire décide de recréer les
grands moments historiques de sa famille
grâce à des personnages de cirque créé
par le musée grévin
nous retrouvons en 1881
en compagnie de mon grand père henri le
8e art qui de breteuil du roi edouard 7
au milieu qui est en fait prince de
galles l'époque qui sera roi un peu plus
tard et de gambetta et les trois
personnages s'entendent pour se dire
qu'il faut maintenant rapprocher la
france et l'angleterre en vue de ce que
l'on appellera plus tard l'entente
cordiale
le marquis décide également de se lancer
dans les années 70 dans les célèbres
contes de perrault pour rendre hommage à
son ancêtre louis de breteuil ministre
des finances sous louis xiv et qui avait
eu à charles perrault comme
collaborateur aujourd'hui 800 sont
représentés c'est beaucoup plus gai
d'introduire des personnages des contes
que des personnages de la vie du château
d'autrefois et c'est que c'est ça l'idée
qu'on a eu en introduisant le chat botté
cendrillon et d'autres et ça nous a
porté chance parce que c'est vrai que
dans l'esprit du public
le château est beaucoup devenu le
château des comtes aujourd'hui encore
des jardiniers des ouvriers des équipes
d'entretien travaillent quotidiennement
dans la structure pour restaurer et
moderniser le château bien sûr qu'il ya
tout souvent des travaux à faire et et
notre rôle est de choisir les couleurs
de restaurer les meubles de restaurer
les tableaux cette pièce a été restauré
l'an dernier par exemple entièrement
avec ce nouveau bleu on est un peu chef
de chef de chantier comme vous le dites
parce qu'il ya tout le temps tout le
temps des travaux à faire un travail qui
paie aujourd'hui le château est visité
par près de 125 mille personnes tous les
ans l'histoire n'est pas encore terminée